il allumait un moment donné il se serait
énervé ils se sont mis à insulter nos
autorités leurs ambassadeurs se livrer à
des activités subversives ici c'est pour
ça vous lui avez demandé par les qui
divise les maliens et lorsqu'ils sortent
pour de façon ingénieuse adressée au
président de la transition chef de
l'état malien nous avons dit que c'en
est trop surtout qu'on subodorait qui
préparait un plan pour vous renversez
vous mais c'était très clair vous
essayer de renverser le gouvernement
toutes les manoeuvres qui se faisait
c'est pour renverser tous ses discours
la segunda illégitime issus des deux
couleurs pour l'achat